[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui le
cinéaste robert guédiguian pour son
livre d'entretiens les lendemains
chanteront peut-il encore et la pianiste
vanessa bd limbs elle pour son nouvel
album consacré à claude debussy et l'on
commence tout de suite par les images
que vous avez choisi tous les deux pour
illustrer notre époque la vôtre venez ça
la voici c'est la coop oui
c'est une image qui m'a marqué car
c'est parce que des enfants qui qui
montre ses panneaux que je trouve assez
sympa souvent j'ai presque eu des
enfances et des autres et des enfants
voilà c'est des très jeunes et qui
appellent à l'action dans la transition
écologique pas aux normes de l'intérêt
de lettres humaines donc encore une fois
l'être humain qui est pas seulement à
l'origine de cette dégradation mais qui
est la finalité ultime mais aussi
vis-à-vis des animaux qui sont
effectivement menace est
forcément engagée en puissant est
innocent et pour moi ça c'est la vraie
vie retour voilà une action qui appelle
à l'action pour elle-même et pas pour
une finalité secondaire est donc souvent
les planètes parce qu'il est faux comme
quand on a l'impression d'ailleurs de
plus en plus que les lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique est en train de
devenir une lutte gérant générationnel
oui motivés par cette grande
charismatique
d'abord vous avez senti bas aussi robert
guédiguian oui mais une urgence d'objets
très très juste que là les jeunes gens
d'aujourd'hui 0 occupe énormément de ça
j'aimerais qu'ils le fassent de manière
plus politique que j'allais dire c'est à
dire par exemple vous pouvez poser la
question à tous les candidats
aujourd'hui deux delà du respect ou non
des accords du giec il dira si vous ne
respectez pas les accords dits jacques
si ça ne figure pas au programme je ne
voterai pas pour vous voilà c'est je ne
pourrais dire ça par exemple à tous les
candidats votre image avoue robert
lavoie si c'est la fiche de votre
prochain film qui sort tout début
janvier
2022 christa magna cum oui si vous
voulez c'est un peu l'idée du film c'est
de réconcilier de twister le socialisme
et l'idée socialiste l'hypothèse
communiste je distingue pas socialisme
et communisme d'impôt pour le pour
l'occasion mais fonctionnement de penser
division à gauche et à toutes les idées
de gauche qui existe depuis deux siècles
pour y avait un petit peu plus de joie
de twist de féliciter de danse de fête à
douala on y reviendra en fin d'émission
est sur ce film
commençons
[Musique]
robert guédiguian vous êtes le
réalisateur de marius et jeannette des
neiges du kilimandjaro du promeneur du
champ de mars de l'armé du crime
votre prochain film donc s'intitule
triste et banale à bamako en attendant
aujourd'hui vous publiez aux liens qui
libèrent un livre d'entretiens avec
votre ami christophe kantcheff rédacteur
en chef adjoint à politis il est
intitulé les lendemains chanteront il
encore vie par les politiques vous
donner votre point de vue que ce soit
sur le mouvement des gilet jaune ou sur
le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
pourquoi un artiste aussi réputés que
vous at-il le besoin d'expliciter son
cheminement intellectuel et politique
j'ai l'impression que c'est typiquement
de gauche un cinéaste comme clint
eastwood signe de droite donc il
estimerait qu'il n'a de compte à rendre
à personne
vous vous expliquiez c'est ça cette
gauche pourquoi s'expliquer c'est aussi
une manière de justifier mais peut-être
ça serait bien que de religion de gauche
s'explique alors que se doit dans le
fond pas dessus de qualité d expliquer
de s'expliquer sur ses motivations et de
s'expliquer surtout sur ses sur ses
désirs ses envies sur ce qu'on aimerait
qu'il advienne je crois ce doc sur son
programme je les ai presque dire mais
moi pour moi si vous voulez le je
considère qu'un que l'essentiel de ma
participation au moins 27 travers quand
même mes films bien entendu mais c'est
un prolongement en fait je crois que
prolonge demande parce qu'il ya des
d'aller filmer les choses qu'on ne veut
pas trop trop trop dire en particulier
des choses que je peux plus abstraite un
peu plus de l'ordre de 2,2 j'allais dire
du concept un peu plus un truc
guillemets c'est un livre de philosophie
je ne suis pas philosophe je travaillais
pas assez la philosophie pour le polo
prétendre jouer mais n'en ont peut-être
d'ailleurs ceci dit il y à aussi dans le
livre là l'idée de deux désirs
inassouvis quoi je vais peut-être jouer
et j'aurais aimé continuer mes études
universitaires
le hasard fait que j'ai pas continuer et
que s'il continue et par d'autres moyens
que j'ai basculé dans le cinéma là je
rebascule un petit peu du côté de
l'université jeunes gens voilà du côté
de lui mais vous n'avez pas l'impression
que un film est bien plus convaincant
que qu'un discours militant ou
universitaire ou même parfois
intellectuelle des l'instant il est trop
précises par le en jeu par quand on
parle de politique bien entendu les
raisons de la colère de john ford les
temps modernes de chaplin c'est
infiniment plus convaincant que les
tests d'avril de l'année je pense oui je
crois je crois mais c'est pas moi c'est
pas abordé le monde de la même année en
fait c'est vrai que la force du cinéma
ou de la de l'art en général d'ailleurs
de la littérature c'est c'est
probablement d'incarner effectivement
aucune idée l'idée est incarné les murs
et par l'émotion et visionner l'émotion
il ya la mise en mouvement donc ça peut
soulever des foules ça doit fonctionner
comme ça c'est trop démonstratif non une
espèce de tout le cinéma démonstratif
non on voit la vitesse que ça il faut
qu'il y ait du mystère accusé de lâcher
à l'appliquer de la vraie vie à un bras
et à ce moment là ça peut effectivement
je crois à interroger plus qu'un projet
à partir des terreaux gaccio de mettre
en mouvement les gens après l'approché
des lectures le plus pointu est
nécessaire aussi il faut bien analyser
le monde de manière extrêmement précises
pour pouvoir le transformer pour voir
sur quel là qu'un moine doit agir très
précisément et intervenir de manière
chirurgicale ou pas opérer quoi pour une
peau ainsi dix ans pour faire nommer taf
c'est pour ça que vous revenez sur votre
cheminement intellectuel et politique
pendant tous ces entretiens vous
racontez des adolescents dans les années
60 vous rêviez de révolution armée en
amérique du sud comme régis debray qu'il
sorte d'idole à l'époque puisqu'il est
parti en bolivie rejoindre che guevara
il a même fait de la prison là bas et
que vous dites aussi vous étiez opposé
à des actions violentes comme celle de
de la bande à baader en allemagne de
l'ouest où deux des brigades rouges en
italie et je me demandais pourquoi est
ce qu a priori c'est la même chose che
guevara de norbert justement d'exporter
la guerre dans les pays et notamment
d'amérique c'était l'amérique du sud
c'est écrit non même en amérique du nord
il disait il faut porter la guerre y
compris dans les lieux de divertissement
et il faut la porte n'est apportée
totalement une bande fm a éclaté à
vietnam dit vietnam s'en viennent à
créer 2 3 plusieurs viennent à la gorge
non je connais mais monsieur c'est
toujours demander s'il aurait pensé
l'attend aide des attentats du
11-septembre che guevara mon avis leur
applaudi à je repars pour quoi ils
parlent roulage europa parce
qu'effectivement la violence générée et
evidian conditionnée par le fait qu'ils
sentent qu'ils vivaient dans des pays de
dictature violence pour moi est légitime
maintenant répondre à la violence par
exemple la glace l'armé du crime que
vous évoquez l'autre jour fait l'armé du
crime sur le titre du cd l'intitulé de
la fiche écrit par les allemands qui a
fait diffuser la propagande autour
cette arme est absolument magnifique qui
étaient fonctionnels ftp mans il est
donc le groupe manouchian le groupement
local affiche rouge et c'est une
histoire qui tient très connu en france
effectivement il s'opposait donc il
tirait il tirait déjà et tu es tu es
déjà par dans la rue n'est déjà pas déjà
et tué des milliers des nazis oui ils
étaient ciblés dans les pas n'importe
qui effectivement tu le violent ce qui
était la seule arme qu'ils avaient à
leur disposition plus il déterre qui et
poings liés par parler d'un sénateur de
dictature donc c'est une violence qui
répondait pour vous la différence entre
la baule et che guevara en bolivie et la
fraction armée rouge en allemagne de
l'ouest où les brigades rouges en italie
c'est le fait que d'autres il ya une
dictature en face à la bolivie le régime
aux boliviens seconde a été comparable
originalement ce moment là et tous les
défauts gaver l'allemagne à ce moment là
d'ailleurs en particulier dans nos
manières de tisanes et papa tout à fait
à ce moment là même pas du tout pour
vous souvent quand on condamner vivement
leur passé nazi environnment et par là
même à ce moment là mais malgré ça et
ceci d'ailleurs explique un parti qui
avait on peut pas analyser la bande à
baader sans savoir que il se révolte et
aussi comme le cinéma de l'époque aussi
d'ailleurs regardez fassbender et c'est
contre cette espèce que dans leurs
parents qui étaient restés pas très
lourd et vainqueur et goûter jeux à
baudelaire ou qui étaient restés
effectivement très proche il avait
conservé d'appareils administratives
souvent à xavier nazie et ses terrasses
qui sait ce qu ici après comme
considérablement résorber mais c'est
vrai nos yeux pays démocratique j'ai
toujours été contre la grèce un pays
démocratique années 70 vous militiez au
parti communiste français
vous avez dû vous en inspirer dans votre
film mon père est ingénieur mais vous
raconter qu'il y avait un grand plaisir
à militer il ya même de la jouissance il
jure mais c'est une activité minitel une
activité hautement aussi intellectuel et
puis à l'ogc nice bat seul dogme est dit
et ça veut dire effectivement que vous
connais avec koné en permanence un
groove avec les amis avec des garçons et
des filles fais pas tu vu le mode
d'existence est conditionné par ça on
réfléchit un sam aussi on va aussi les
manceaux auraient dit les livres en
sabre de sortir ses intonations se
retrouve face à des gens ou su rectifier
voilà ça indiffère
très souvent joué mais c'est passionnant
d'essayer de convaincre quelqu'un avoir
le goût de ça je dis dans le livre j'ai
le goût de la conversation c'est pour ça
que tu a bavardé avec mon ami kane chef
mais effectivement c'est une si tu ne
joues animal sauvage aime bien parler
avec vous je veux dire je l'idée de
parler avec quelqu'un qui soit
convaincue ou pas qu'ils s'opposent ou
pas ou peu importe s'il est petit peu
d'accord sur des principes je pense
comme un petit peu plus vrai dans la
conversation oui ainsi elle devrait
opposition je crois que la parole se
bloquent mais sinon c'est très très très
très agréable et très
j'ai toujours imaginé qu'il devait y
avoir quelque chose de frustrant à à ce
que dans le nombre de gens que l'on
contacts que l'on démarche que ce soit
sur un marché ou chez lui 1 j'ai
l'impression que on a recruté très très
peu alors je me suis dit ça doit être
oui bien sûr mais les bécanes la recrue
turn est très heureuse donc c'est pas
une joie aussi de deschamps qui fait
qu'ils changent d'idée c'est si c'est
pas un cadeau que de recruter d'ailleurs
parfois de faire voter quelqu'un plutôt
que tel candidat que porte alors une
écurie compris parfois au niveau local
comme souvent je pense qu'on a on a fait
changer d'idée où on a on a
poussé déjà à voter pour tel ou tel
parti à ce moment là vous avez quand
vous réalisez un film aujourd'hui vous
avez cette idée derrière la tête de
faire changer d'avis éventuellement
quelqu'un qui va le regarder oui oui je
pense vraiment je pense que mais
peut-être je dise toujours peut-être une
seule personne s'il ya une personne qui
changent la vie c'est déjà pas mal mais
mais changer d'avis c'est un bien grand
mot mais l'a par exemple le film tonnes
de thon va parler la
5 janvier j'veux dire si ce film pouvait
simplement poussé déjà à considérer que
ce qui s'est passé en afrique dans les
années 60 n'est toujours pas résolu
aujourd'hui et qu'il faudrait peut-être
chercher du côté de certains ne voient
que est explorée à ce moment là pour les
réouvrir ses voix l'aps se sont fermées
ce sera en broussaille et on pourrait
dire voilà qu'il faudrait peut-être à
chercher de ce côté là pour que
l'afrique se développe aujourd'hui je
gêne je serais ravie je serais très
heureux et je crois que des gens vont
penser ça si j'ai oublié un petit peu
cette histoire là donc le film va au
moins au minimum la remémorer la
remettre en lumière comme je lé fais
d'ailleurs je dirais que les films
historiques que j'ai voulu faire comme
avec la ferme à nokia bien sûr l'affiché
rouge ou là je pense que s'il n'y avait
pas le film l'histoire est cette
histoire était un peu oubliée donc la
fonction du cinéma aussi de l'art en
général peut être aussi parfois de
remettre en lumière des choses qui
étaient dépités des très belles
histoires en fait et l époque vous le
dites vous même dans les années soixante
dix les militants et notamment de gauche
et plus particulièrement du parti
communiste avait une proposition claire
à me faire aux gens ça n'a plus rien à
voir aujourd'hui il ya une aversion dit
vous aujourd'hui ce sont les les quêtes
et capitaliste qui sont des réformateurs
et effet les gens de gauche et notamment
les classes populaires les classes les
moins favorisées qui sont devenus
conservatrice oui il faut s'expliquer un
peu c'est à dire elles ont été je pense
je pense que tous les travailleurs tous
les pauvres gens votent comme si victor
hugo ce saut sont obligés aujourd'hui de
se défendre contre les coudes les
coussins cesse de 2,2 de la bourgeoisie
et firmin et du capitalisme comme comme
je le disais un livre effectivement ils
sont obligés de ceux de se battre vous
regardez ce qu'ils ont acquis d'ailleurs
il ya des gens qui avaient beaucoup
d'humour aujourd'hui 10 et les conflits
sociaux c'est pas des acquis sociaux
c'est vrai que c'est pas mal d'ailleurs
de dire simple ce qui en fait ils sont
battus pendant deux siècles pour en
arriver où ils sont là et aujourd'hui on
n'assiste qu'à des régressions sociales
encore récemment avec la loi sur le
chômage bon qui est qui et bientôt la
précédente journée mais bientôt sur les
retraites ce questionnaire au printemps
les faits ils veulent que la gauche qui
n'a au live furie certes bcao imaginer
la suite bien sûr mais la situation là
aujourd'hui concrètement faut que le
fait que le mouvement social en fait est
amené à essayer de conserver ce qu'il a
conquis plutôt qu'à proposer quelque
chose de nouveau voilà et du coup il
semblerait qu'ils aient des
conservateurs qui sont du côté du
mouvement social et des
intrigues et des transformateurs je
dirais pas des progressistes parce que
moi c'est pas des progrès et des gens
qui en tout cas propose de nouvelles
choses du côté du patronat voit la série
ci dessus des versions étrange et c'est
vrai que depuis la gauche ne se remet
pas d'avoir perdu effet tiré cette
vision alternative c'est à dire depuis
que depuis que le jeu dure depuis le
depuis 89 depuis la fin de l'urss et
dieu sait si l'urss à mon avis n'a pas
été communiqué musso g ou très peu outre
une seconde au tout début mais elle a
été suggéré que l'union soviétique voilà
et c'est vrai que depuis la perte gamin
de cet idéal à cette alternative qui
avaient été pensées politiques à même
par un siècle après siècle et demi de
travaux divers et variés de mouvements
sociaux de lutte etc de perte de cette
idée a fait perdre la gauche ce seront
ses dires sa morale en fait c'est
fondamental de kidnapper les
propositions le propose dans la cadre du
capitalisme des choses parfois pas
toujours pas assez à mon avis parce que
je crois que pour qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui il faudrait que l'on propose
sans cesse des choses dans le cadre du
capitalisme c'est ce que j'essaie
effectué le dire dans le vous même le
livre ne croyait plus à la fin du
capitalisme
importe la fin du capitalisme ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le communisme déjà là
dans le capitalisme voilà et puisque
j'avais l'un des moments communiste en
fait je crois qu'il y en a beaucoup il
ya des tas de gens d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui en particulier des jeunes
gens dont on parlait tout à l'heure qui
font des expériences en permanence et
qui sont pour moi des bovins communiste
et vos filles blondes mouvement
communiste générale tout ce que vous
aimez ces radios fm moment là un peu
comme jean renoir l'avait fait avec le
crime de monsieur lange oui voila je
suis effectivement de montrer
effectivement des ddd des moments où les
individus et le et des collectifs se se
fonctionne très bien ensemble en
harmonie là j'étais vraiment comment et
pourquoi ça ne dure pas au pourquoi ça
n'a pas fonctionné parce qu'à travers la
réflexion nous pourquoi ça n'a pas
fonctionné un peu essayé de fait raison
que nous avons fonctions voilà je pense
qu'effectivement moi je crois qu'être
communiste aujourd'hui c'est être dans
une de ces futurs maîtres d une éthique
communiste il faut que ce soit une règle
de vie que ce que le moral en fait est
ce que vous créez du communisme autour
de moi est ce que vous avez vécu vous
des mamans communiste comme vous les
appelez au contre manque dans vos films
j'entends dont beaucoup je pense même
que je crois même que l'entreprise en
fait de production que nous avons créé à
gaza oui à quatre films vous situer le
collectif collectif qui dure depuis 25
ans que maintenant nous que ça prouve
bien que vous avez dû améliorer un
moment vous dites on a été obligés
d'introduire un système de primes oui au
fond que les producteurs tout seul à
tous la même la même somme ça
fonctionnait mal oui c'est vrai mais
souvent c'est justement à ce moment
communistes se corrige général tu n'y a
pas quelque chose de figé destitution
analyser il ya en permanence une
adaptation aurait elle enfin tout
simplement je devrais être fou pour
penser que les modèles qui est juste une
fois pour toutes donc il faudrait
adapter en permanence mesure vous avez
connu des mouvements des mouvements
communistes
j'ai vécu un rossi 81 donc il y a un
sens des communautés très fort où
j'étais au conservatoire tchaïkovski de
moscou je ne sais pas si c'était des
moments communiste mais c'étaient des
moins des communions
c'est pas mal c'est déjà pas mal
mais je vois qu'il ya beaucoup je crois
que dans les zones à défendre par
exemple de ce que vous sortez d'un
certes escouade de certains des jeunes
gens partout où dans certaines
entreprises surtout une coopérative qui
dansent en nom collectif qu'il est venu
du chômage / unissent quelques amis se
réunissent et vraiment eu le boîte et
son associé et puis voilà et puis si ça
dure dix ans c'est très bien peu importe
si vous le 10 ans pour des raisons
diverses et variées sa capote ça m'est
égal je crois que les loups le pouvoir
aujourd'hui devrait encourager
effectivement la création permanence du
moment parce que c'était un homme debout
un communiste à dire de moins solidaires
nous mêmes plus collectif devait mériter
un permanent ce serait la fin de la
lutte des classes en vous y croyez à la
lutte des classes gagne un moment
communiste dans une entrevue avec oui je
suis heureux que c'est la fin de la
lutte des classes non mais là c'est vrai
que la fin des juges des classes c'est
effectivement s'il ya pas de classe
ouais
y'a pas de classe tout simplement les
classes ne s'opposent plus
inéluctablement ne sorte dans les
moments que vous décrivez tout à coup le
patron et ses employés peuvent se
retrouver totalement en harmonie oui
mais cela n'est pas loin de ce qu'on
n'est pas loin de là des formes si là
aussi diverses mais n'est pas loin de ce
qu'on appelle la coopérative mais le
coopérative par définition il n'y a pas
de livres de classe au 8e trou alors de
la richesse donc si c'est vrai que le le
le le but ultime fin du mouvement
communiste serait de créer une société 5
mars à la lutte des classes a primé pour
notamment les gens de votre génération
sur les luttes antiracistes sur les
luttes féministes sur les luttes
pourrait dire et même l'étendre
générationnel puisque certains s'en
réclament aujourd'hui
c'est qu'une erreur c'est une erreur sur
erreur relative c'est à dire que je
crois que la lutte des classes en
dernière instance en fait état et là est
le moteur des sociétés voilà et le
moteur de l'histoire encore aujourd'hui
une phase on a bien su bien sûr à
aujourd'hui si vous voulez comme je veux
pas des rentrées dans des définitions
classe ouvriers employés petit clavier
ctrl jeudi jeudi mettons entre les
pauvres et des riches voilà sa légalité
voilà les inégalités moi je crois que
c'est ça le monde et les inégalités
sociales les vous éviter bien sûr genre
les inégalités c'est que les inégalités
entre les âges voit là j'avoue une
erreur par rapport à ça tu as du 10 ou
20 que on les a considérés comme
secondaires en fait alors qu'elle était
seule seconde pour moi c'est à dire ne
sont pas ce godet en seconde ça veut
dire qu'il faut se préoccuper autant et
qu'elle est que dans le ressenti de
certaines personnes c'est plus fort qu
effectivement l'oppression vous en avez
très bien dans votre film oui aussi bien
de dieu du racisme de du féminisme et
des revendications peuvent avoir les
classes jeunes parents sont plus anciens
oui mais parce que dans le ressenti il
faut se méfier de ça je crois je
reconnais le il ya déjà en particulier
je pense à martigues et au racisme ans
puisque je crois que ce que l'on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui
on en parle beaucoup quasiment pour la
coiffe des gens affirment quasiment
qu'ils sont racistes aujourd'hui ce qui
est quand même une chose vraiment
terrifiante puisque pendant tout cas
longtemps le racisme ckx dominé on peut
dire on ne ne s'affichait pas
aujourd'hui il s'affiche quasi ben voilà
mais le belge est toutes les options
identitaire s'affiche au fond on notre
identité mais laura silsby que si ce
n'est pas une option identité parfois
c'est de la panique identit le racisme
le sexisme
oui mais peu importe d'où sa dsk même
sentiment à trop se considère tout
simplement dire que les hommes en face
de nous ne sommes pas des ogres c'est ça
le racisme même pas forcément vouloir
dire ça tu avais dit qu'ils sont moins
intéressants je dis que j'ai au moins
intéressants qu'ils y firent dur ça veut
dire que c'est pas désormais ou que je
sais je sais pas comment le dire donc je
trouve ça effectivement assez a trop
secours est tout à fait justifiée
condamnable c'est condamnable d'ailleurs
en france aujourd'hui en juniors voilà
donc je passe d'y visionner là je
comprends qu'effectivement déjà de
l'identité dans la réalité humaine et
nier c'est sûr je considère que cette
oppression là est plus forte que
l'oppression effectivement
capitaliste que l'exploitation de
l'homme par l'homme dans les rapports
économiques et sociaux voilà donc ça
c'est vrai qu'on a on n'a peut-être pas
assez mesuré jeudi au jeu parle moi
d'ailleurs moi même je vais là-bas ces
mesures et réfléchi à ça il ya 30 ou 40
ans parce qu'effectivement l'oppression
capitaliste passer d'abord voilà donc
7,7 cette oppression lama paraissait pas
aussi ne sautait pas aux yeux comme
émotion toujours dus aux yeux doux mais
on va peut-être d'ailleurs ça quelque
chose à voir avec le film avec lui sa
maman qu est-ce que je traite gamin de
ce moment là aussi pour ça que la fin du
colonialisme mais aussi delà de la
frontière entre les du fossé entre les
générations et ça c'est quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup frappé dans votre
cinéma parce que pendant très longtemps
on a vu notamment dans les caisses
populaires mais pas seulement les jeunes
être intégré par les plus âgés nous y
avait comme ça une espèce de passage de
témoin le dernier auquel je pensais
jarre depardieu dans vincent françois
paul et les ont été pris comme ça par
piccoli
montant reggiani qu'il tire vers eux
qu'il intègre même si par ailleurs il
appartient des classes sociales
différentes d'ailleurs vous dans vos
films vous avez assez bien montrer dès
le premier d'ailleurs dernière était
mais aussi dans les neiges du
kilimandjaro dans la lah comment
s'appelait à la haye la vieille dame
aura ses bras vous montrez bien à quel
point les jeunes aujourd'hui ont du mal
à trouver leur place et au fond que
assez rapidement on les qualifie de
voyous et ça évite justement de leur
faire une place oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai que la transmission se faisait de
manière un peu automatique naturel à ce
moment là mais la transmission se
faisait aussi par le travail tout
simplement quelqu'un on y travaille oui
parce qu'avec du travail c'est à dire
que les années de l'ouverture je suis
délais des jeux le jeu à 18 ans le
travail est souvent dans la même
entreprise de cloper et sûreté interne
du travail à la même heure ils allaient
ensemble d'un local syndical habilité à
sable il faisait des gravasses convoi
qu'elle était verte ma vallée de john
ford et gris mineurs voilà que des films
quelques jours le plus bouleversant 2 2
de john ford tout à fait donc la
transmission se faisait de manière un
peu automatique c'est ça qui s'est perdu
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que même à
ce moment là je sais que moi ce qu'on
appelait le conflit générationnel des
jeunes 10,80 quelque chose qui m'a
jamais concerné j'ai jamais été un
conflit que mon père jamais nous avons
toujours été d'accord malgré donc les
carnages malgré l'écart générationnel
voilà je crois que je crois toujours
aujourd'hui que c'est possible il espère
sans doute dialectique dans nos
transmissions mossad rapport d'ailleurs
maître élève aussi entre c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui s'est fait l activité
l'approvisionnement aso à quelqu'un qui
est plus jeune de création fille soit
des enfants etc ce rapport là aussi
c'est casser le fil s'est rompu les gens
sur lâché un petit peu tout seul si je
crois les jeunes générations aujourd'hui
on achète tout seul mais ils reprennent
du poil de la bête et je je je je pense
qu'il crée un leurs créations
aujourd'hui il réclame mais parce que
l'humanité doit toujours réclamé ils
réclament du collectif en fait voilà ils
réclament du commun pour pas dire du
communisme pur
voilà je reprend évidemment cesare ce
terme il ya un problème de démographie
non tout simplement les jeunes sont
moindre bruit qu'avant on le voit dans à
peu près tous les arts d'ailleurs me
semble-t-il dans l'art contemporain dans
les années 60 vous preniez la liste des
100 artistes y en avait 30 qui avaient
moins de 30 ans aujourd'hui en à 0 vous
prenez le start système en france la
plupart des des acteurs bien payés ont
plus de 40 ans
ce que ceux de moins de vingt-cinq
aliments n'existe pas je sais pas
comment c'est dans la musique est ce
qu'il ya un problème aussi la musique on
a du mal à se faire sa place quand on
est jeune
disons-le est sûrement à cette
génération encore plus jeunes la mienne
havas offrir encore plus de ces années
kovy des dix ans
mais oui sinon il y à il ya toujours eu
beaucoup de jeunes qui veulent s'imposer
dans le monde de la musique
je sais pas si c'est s'il vient en moins
qu'avant ça chez sage aujourd'hui on a
quand on a 25 ans on a face de soi les
baby boomers qui sont toujours là oui
mais bon de moins en moins vous me direz
mais en fait ils sont là en tout cas ce
sont leurs goûts qui dicte un peu les
est ce qu'on va écouter comme musique
est ce qu'on va aller regarder au cinéma
pas forcément un cadeau je crois pas
vraiment je je je je crois que vais je
sais pas tout ce qui existe aujourd'hui
sur un cerneau musical pour les jeunes
de 30 un
goûter mais les parents non non non
c'est très différent et des musiques et
des parents qui sont devenus des
classiques les rolling stones par
exemple dans l'exemple le plus évident
quoi mais sinon tout la musique
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait par exemple qui
est dit au rap par exemple est quelque
chose que nous ne connaissions pas du
tout vous en moi oui oui vous êtes vus
suis plus vieux beaux exploits de leur
père quand même
on va faire une pause robert guédiguian
on va s'intéresser à bénaissa benelli
moselle et puis on terminera l'émission
continuera sur votre livre et sur le
film en janvier pose
[Musique]
vanessa medellin moselle vous êtes
kallisté vous sortez un nouveau disque
consacré à claude debussy pourquoi
encore et toujours que le début si
oui notamment c'est mon deuxième album
après mon premier en 2018 pour la
commémoration du centenaire de la mort
des bustiers en 1918
début si c'est un compositeur que je
sens que je ressens très proche de ma
sensibilité
avec ravel il a renouvelé la conception
de l'instrument on peut dire qu après
frédéric chopin c'est vraiment un début
aussi qui a révolutionné
la technique la proche et qui aussi
c'est un compositeur qui représente
aussi l'évolution de l'instrument on a
plus des instruments comme en avait à
l'époque du romantisme mais donc on a
avec notre ciel et au delà aujourd'hui
il est proche de celui ci il est il est
loin de celui utilisé shopper oui bien
sûr les piano de chopin sont appelés des
biens importés et donc les pianos coquet
que j'ai aujourd'hui que j'utilise un
concert c'est pas les mêmes débuts si
les gens mais c'est quand même ça avec
des bus si on se rapproche de
l'instrument contemporain et donc dans
sa musique
dans ce prélude surtout il y a
la nuit la luminosité la rigueur c'est
ce sont des préludes assez sombre mais
plein plein de lumière tant d'espoirs et
cette musique remplie vraiment mon
imaginaire avec des couleurs des images
des histoires
des contes des fantasy et des sensations
sonores d'ailleurs
les inspirations des périodes de doute
et gyan livre que je viens d'enregistrer
dans mon nouveau album avec kelly le
joyeuse et les types de scanners
sont souvent des inspirations
pittoresque était encore plus que les
pelles ou tapez vous le dire d énergie
torres cuisson des images sont des
peintures mais aussi des d inspiration
littéraire donc on a put up and on a ça
- patrick charles dickens on a aussi des
inspirations exotiques donc l'inde avec
ces vases des canucks mais aussi
les noirs américaine avec l'antenne un
pan du ragtime qui elle kate works qui
inspire toujours début si après on a
aussi des personnages un peu dada qui
même si seven ou beaucoup pas prêt mais
comme les général la ville qui était un
clown qui tournait
un tout europe mais aussi les
inspirations très personnelle ce qu'on
appelle la publicisation du privé chez
début si donc par exemple dans l'isle
joyeuse
il vit 7,1 cette histoire d'amour
incroyable avec emma barda qui viendra
après sa femme et donc c'est une pièce
plein d'efforts et d'un enthousiasme et
aussi dans le style d'un score les coins
des enfants il y a beaucoup
d'inspiration et fantine donc c'est un
recueil qu'il a écrits qui a dédiée à sa
petite main sa fille donc à claude
aimant qui prend les nommer des ses
parents claude debussy et moubarak donc
c'est dédiée à claude et moi qui avais à
peine trois ans quand il allait
prochainement il a fait les chouchous
voilà et donc il y à des morceaux dédiés
par exemple aux doudounes des chouchous
de moubarak cet petit éléphant jimbo
sûrement inspiré par par 7 à l'astral f1
qui est devenu les gens qui tournent
toute l'europe
donc il y à la belle 16 pour jimpo
je vous interromps va vous écouter jouer
du debussy parce qu'il y en a qui nous
écoutent ou qui ne regarde en ce moment
qu'ils disent mais c'est quoi debussy on
vous écoute jouer la fille aux cheveux
de lin par exemple
[Musique]
e
oh
quand j'écoute du but si je pense
toujours à la pâture de bâtisses
baptiste et pourtant beaucoup plus jeune
que du but si ben fin à ce moment là
mathis c les fauves c'est l'avant garde
en peinture
debussy c'est l'avant garde en musique
on lit qu'elle a été véritablement et ça
j'ai du mal à le mesurer l'impact de
debussy l'impact de matisse le voit mais
l'impact du but si c'est quoi pour vous
c'est énorme et on part toujours d
arnaud foubert comme les paires de
l'avant garde les pères de la musique
contemporaine classique mais plus que
j'avançais plus que j'ai approfondi des
bucyk d'ailleurs j'ai c'est les
compositions qui est jugé plus
enregistrer plus approfondies avec
peut-être franz liszt g mais dis que
c'est en fait claude debussy que cette
évidence est cette influence
pour toute la musique aussi la technique
par exemple des bus s'ils disaient à
marguerite long qui était sa fidèle à
internet qui est il fallait
voler sur sur les claviers mais pénétrer
dans les notes d'autres donc qu'il y a
cette volonté dénier les côtés
percussive
des lancements qui est en fait les
pianos c'est un instrument à percussion
en les rapprochant
plus au chant et aux instruments à
cordes avec aussi c'est tous âges
fondamentale et révolutionnaire du pedal
vous avez debussy et bouquins beaucoup
j'ai pas utiliser d'un des films aux uv
l'occasion j'ai obligé failli g fit ssii
ravel pavane à plusieurs fois de deux
fois ouais donne deux films différents
d'affaires jemil j'utilise mon souffle
il prouve comme j'y suis attaché et que
je dois aussi très cinématographique un
puce la pavane parce que ça va passer
vraiment du lot une émotion à une autre
plusieurs fois dans le morceau et puis
debussy ces deux c'était du compositeur
préféré d'alexandre desplat
pour musiciens de films français et kaka
kaka fait son premier film avec moi et
que je connais bien depuis des années
qui avaient travaillé on a travaillé 3 3
x 3 4 fois
il parle souvent de buch et son
inspiration
donc le côté contemporain et
révolutionnaire aussi de sa musique
c'était aussi dans ses côtés
fragmentaires et
dans cet obstacle qu'on voit surtout
dans les périodes de deuxième livre est
bien sûr qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
difficiles à l' écoute et qui sont qui
ont été détruits dépouilles
création mise en doute par les
historiens les journalistes surtout à
l'époque dès débuts c'est parce qu'ils
sont vraiment il y a beaucoup
d'abstraction dans cette musique il n'ya
pas seulement il n'y a pas comme comme
dans les premières livres et lens
l'inspiration de la nature mais c'est
vraiment et aussi il ya ce côté
fragmentaire qui est pour le pôle sites
ayant que la ville garde un moment
l'universalité des choses à propos de la
nature justement on va vous écoutez
interpréter ce qu'a vu le vent d'ouest
là on est typique dans debussy à la fois
le côté pictural de deux missions il
debussy et puis sa façon de nous
restituer la nature ce qui a vu le vent
d'ouest extrait d'un vanessa benelli
moselle
[Musique]
le
et
e
m
[Musique]
et
e
vous serez vous venez ça en concert à la
philharmonie le 28 novembre dans nino
rota intime avec l' orchestre de paris
j'aime beaucoup d'une route à grand
compositeur mais vous voulez mais aussi
grand compositeur des musiques notamment
de de federico fellini mais aussi du
parrain est très très belles mélodies
mais bon quand j'ai vu vous étiez aux
programmes j'ai pensé à khatia
buniatishvili qui est leur dernier album
joug dieu ennio morricone
j'adore ennio morricone pour moi c'est
un immense compositeur mais c'est pas la
même chose c'est pas au même niveau
c'est comme quand tu y as bu munitis
ville il joue
la javanaise de gainsbourg sur son
dernier album tout ce qu'elle nous
montre ces de gainsbourg c'est pas au
niveau qu est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression même si ce sont de très
grands compositeurs de musique populaire
simplement que ça n'a rien à voir avec
debussy avec ravel avec avec chopin ou
avec liszt c'est un autre genre la
musique de film il ya des compositeurs
qui font qu et ça c'est vraiment
considérer un autre genre de musique
comme les jazz
1 comme la pop et donc il y a d'ailleurs
chez mory connais beaucoup des pièces
qui ne sont pas fait pour le cinéma et
qui sont des merveilleuses oeuvres d'art
donc défi pour les amateurs de morricone
dont je fais partie sont beaucoup moins
intéressante que ce qu'il a pu pour
l'utile et basé sont beaucoup moins il
me semble beaucoup moins connu et donc
il y as peut-être aussi ses côtés ennio
morricone et pas cinéma découvrir comme
d'ailleurs ni alors tu as une roulotte a
écrit trois concertos pour piano
orchestre
mais évidemment c'est musique pour films
sont des chefs-d'oeuvre d'ailleurs la
suite du classement va que je vais jouer
dimanche
moi avec les images du film qui c'est un
film absolument impressionnant étonnant
c'est voilà c'est c'était une musique
pour laquelle aussi là il avait su les
david de l'onatel et donc moi je la
trouve géniale génialissime le casanova
qui a été détesté à l'époque je me
souviens à l'époque tout le monde
attendait ce film c'est est
détesté par tout le monde
bien sûr je suis gentil oui oui film
très impressionnant à l'époque oui mais
un pc ce jeu vaut choisir après je crois
que j'étais moi j'ai une religion est
évidemment de fellini mais je crois que
donne m en hauteur on a mis compris ce
qu'il rate on aime tous d une hauteur
voilà donc donc pas brouiller la rater
je vais pas juger très bien interview de
fellini oui je sais pas quoi avec
ce personnage c'était son expression
mais il n'a pas su quoi faire avec
quelque chose et 82 films aujourd'hui
sont très très film passionnant alors
justement puisqu'on parle de cinéma
robert guédiguian pourquoi vous êtes
vous intéressé à cette période très
particulière de l'afrique au début des
années 60 dans twixt à bamako donc votre
prochain film qui sort en janvier le 5
janvier exactement twist à bamako soit
162 au mali au moment où fusent on est
juste après l'indépendance moment où il
ya une véritable expérience de
collectivisation au mali a tout à fait
ça fait super expérience au mali
d'ailleurs mais omanis à la durée on pas
qu'au mali à plusieurs pays
effectivement de l'afrique de l'ouest
qui choisissent pour se développer dans
l'indépendance en fait qui choisissent
la voie socialiste et d'autres pays
choisissent une voix capitaliste le mali
fait partie de ceux qui ont choisi cette
voie là et ça se passe plutôt bien
pendant un certain temps je veux dire à
piller pas plutôt bien les commerçants
les agriculteurs font leur fan fan mais
la bourgeoisie le fait qu'on vit alors
nommé aujourd'hui n'est jamais heureuse
que l'ue prenne effectivement ses
profits bien entendu de la bourgeoisie
l'équivalent de la bourgeoisie ce petit
bolide en temps là bas ce cas les grands
commerçants de bamako était quand même
ils avaient de l'argent et les féodaux
dans les villages aussi les chefs de
village qui avait beaucoup de têtes de
bétail tout ça a été aussi très riche ce
qu'il faut maintenant qu'ils qui
fomentent et qui petit à petit means de
révolution minent cette expérience
jusqu'à effectivement la détruire la
fait retomber avec l'aide de dieu le
dira de l'ancien pays colonisateur bien
sûr afin se regarder ça très bon oeil
évidemment la fin de l'expérience je ne
sais pas durer quelques années quand va
durer plus longtemps et un butin et si
tu n'es pas très regretté où il commença
aujourd'hui qui étude d'une époque c'est
modibo keita qui était que je vais la
lire en version 68 par les militaires
oui mais c'est un vrai socialiste
wiki à puce a eu une politique je veux
dire c'est à dire celui des rares
enfants et futures il n'y a pas eu en
afrique de corruption de malversation de
l'attribution de deux prix village haut
fonctionnaire fait que c'était ça se
passait plutôt bien quoi donc c'est
vraiment une c'est une période aussi où
je joue je tenais à montrer comment gens
n'ont parlé un petit peu de chaleur je
sais ce que cette exaltation liée à la
fin 3 2 souvent la fête révolutionnaire
on peut dire c'est à ce moment-là
similaire à ce qu'on vivait à cuba ou
même maintenant voilà est arrivé on est
en pleine époque avec 22 buts et wiz du
rock'n roll et donc les jeunes gens qui
sont mes personnages en particulier qui
sont des jeunes militants très idéaliste
très convaincu qu'ils vont aller au
fameux faut effectivement du début du
xixe désert malien pour apporter
officiellement la parole devra cultiver
de la collectivisation et tout ça est
les campagnes entre le soir et troquent
leur tri pour des costumes blancs la
commsision affiches ou des costumes les
plus extravagants possible pour aller
c'est notre vie c'est le rock'n'roll
dans des boîtes de nuit il y avait 200
boîtes de 2,5 club de danse à bamako on
évalue à 200 en tout cas dans les années
70 que c'était là c'était à faire de la
musique en permanence joueurs de
l'afrique c'est vraiment le berceau de
là toute la musique populaire du 20e
siècle et est ce que vous avez joué de
la musique classique en afrique pas
encore d'accord mais il y en a très peu
ça veut pas dire qu'ils n'écoutent pas
mais les musiciens classiques se rendent
peu souvent en afrique ça veut dire
qu'on peut vraiment faire quelque chose
là-bas des vélos mais encore plus une
scène qui n'a pas encore développé donc
il ya peut-être une carte blanche qu'ont
fait qu'on peut vraiment développer et
moi je suis je suis très ouvert et j'ai
très hâte qu'ils étaient ces pays
développés encore plus parce que tu es
très drôle c'est que l'europe le twist
tout ce qui revient en afrique à ce
moment là c'est comme des versions
abâtardie de leur musique à eux oui
c'est inspiré s'est inspiré retravailler
puis ça revient sur travers ce lundi là
bas tout à fait de faire et est donc il
ya toujours quelque chose d'assez
amusant moi je me souviens d'avoir
rencontré des africains qui m'explique y
trouver céline dion formidable et et je
me disais comment un africain pouvait
mais fait union bah oui peu a pas de
problème et parlez-moi de marseille
parce que vous êtes le cinéaste
marseillais aujourd'hui c'est une
vieille tradition française a décidé à
c'est toujours toujours un et expliquez
moi pourquoi une ville comme marseille
s'entiche tel régulièrement de
personnages tels que bernard tapie ou
didier da à oui on a eu les deux
versions récemment à ça il fait fasciné
par raoult pendant la porte la pandémie
puis ensuite pas moi on a perdu bien
d'un répit et là marseille avait l'air
alors j'imagine bien que ses patrons lui
de lâcher m mais quand même il y en
avait une bonne partie qui avait l'air
tellement malheureux d'avoir quitté b
d'avoir été de 17 bernard tapie comme si
bernard tapie avait fait quelque chose
pour les marseillais il y avait de
l'envié nre il ya quelque chose
moi j'étais pas très sensible ni à
bernard tapie dit un nid à c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont posé la question il fait que
vous avez le temps pourquoi j'ai essayé
de vous le dire mais je ne suis pas sûr
d'avoir raison de le savoir vraiment
mais il ya quelque chose dans cette
ville qui est réfractaire voilà qui
réfractaires à tout pouvoir autre que
celui de la ville et même assez bien pas
celui de la ville c'est celui du
quartier c'est celui du village du
bistrot dans lequel embarras quelque
chose de absolument irréductibles voilà
c'est eric sa permanence donc c'est vrai
que tout ce qui vide de donc on aime y
est il ya donc une espèce de fascination
pour les fortes têtes pour les
capitaines d'industrie pour tapis pour
un toubib qui gueule sans arrêt pour
route bon il ya une espèce de
fascination pour des matamores voilà le
dire autrement mieux quelque chose un
fan faro si vous ne voulez
les ne flattait jamais marseillais se
flatte suffisamment lui même est quelque
chose de type là voilà je trouve je
parlais tout à l'heure en attendant
de l'italie avec vous effectuerez je
disais ça me fait évidemment penser à
naples par exemple à naples est une
ville ou un peu comme un cd ville qui en
soi au par leur histoire ont une espèce
de d'autonomie relative par rapport au
pays voilà marseille a toujours été et
que les deux tours vous le savez là au
début du vieux port n'ont pas été faites
pour protéger marseille de l'extérieur
ces détours qui a été bâti par colbert
pour tirer sur les marseillais qui
manifestaient et quelques voilà voilà
pourquoi on redevient de ce cas-là ce
cas là c'est des excès un soin général
c'est plutôt quelque chose que j'aime
bien un anarchisme de tous les jours
pendant najib politique ou théoriques
mais quelque chose de l'ordre de l'art
de deux mois j'ai même eu chaud mais
j'aime bien ça a quelque chose de
l'ordre de jeu reste debout je vous tout
le monde fait tous les hommes se voir ça
veut aussi dire ça donc ça c'est plutôt
pas mal après évidemment quand sa porte
sur des jarres comme sûr déçu déjà
d'admis voyous science et les intimes
qui m'intéresse moi vous avez joué à
marseille et à naples c'est la même
chose quand on pour une musicienne
de marseille ça veut dire que voilà il
ya ses côtés très passionnel
des napolitains que j'aime vraiment
beaucoup et moi j'adore naples comme
marseille parce que je les trouve une
ville très anglais en italien allegri ce
ciment ça veut dire heureuse et très
colorés
donc personnellement après il à ses
côtés justement orgueilleuse des
napolitains qui est et que je trouve
voilà c'est quelque chose je pense qu'il
y allait même chose à marseille c'est
peut-être là c'est une réaction aussi
décevoir au moins j'ai peur de se voir
attaquer peut être du reste du pays donc
ça provoque une hyper actions et je sais
pas peut-être que c'est ça puisque vous
parlez de politique et corbeyrier dit
guillaume il fut un temps où la musique
était politique
elle était même souvent révolutionnaires
j'ai l'impression que c'est fini il
reste plus que les in la musique
militaire et puis quelques chansons
engagées mais j'ai l'impression que la
musique a totalement déserté la
politique qu'est ce que vous avez cette
impression vous aussi mincir ou la
politique déserté les musiques des
quotas
dans les années 60 par exemple en italie
quand le pouvoir est divisé la gauche
après la culture et donc les partis de
gauche soutenait beaucoup les artistes
c'est pourquoi beaucoup d'artistes ont
adhéré au parti communiste comme une
sortie très connus qui ont
public publiquement
comment dire à
exprimer leurs préférences politiques
comment claudio abbado maurizio pollini
et donc c'était aussi voilà en
collaboration entre les arts autour
d'eva non plus donc voilà on ne peut pas
dire que là les leur musique est devenue
politique forte qui se sont exprimés on
a eu la même chose en france ce n'est
pas cette impression robert guédiguian
que qu'au fond la musique n'est plus
politique et sa méthode alors qu'elle a
été fortement
donc je crois qu'il a toujours je je je
crois qu'il ya toujours vous avez la
musique c'était aussi dans la musique un
son d'ensemble considère aussi la
variété bien des nuances à dire que bien
tenu dans la dans la variété que puis
dans la variété contemporaine et des
choses
caméra du rap hyper engagé quand on
parle de tout ça sur mansion d'orelsan
bon il ya des choses extrêmement
d'hommes dans les textes et des
interventions
des modifications à l'intérieur même de
la musique dans une modernisation du rap
de transformation plutôt d'ailleurs que
modernisation je crois qu'il se passe
des choses en musique aussi la musique
classique et c'est moins évident on
prend tout cela sonne toujours au
répertoire parfois très anciens parfois
un petit peu moins qu'elle sait debussy
mais choper en même temps plus anciens
alors là c'est juste c'est plein la
position des musiciens qui est politique
ou pas est-ce que le musicien qu'on veut
certes elles l'ont fait d'ailleurs faute
des concerts avec
des palestiniens et des israéliens font
des concerts dans les banlieues
gratuit rue rosa et c'est là c'est pas
la musique à ce moment là qu'il est
c'est le musicien qui veut avoir qui
veut que la musique qui va porter cette
musique a des seins des milieux plus
populaires par exemple et qui fait la
démarche je vous remercie tous les deux
d'avoir participé à ces émissions les
landes les lendemains chanteront il
encore c'est le titre du du livre
d'entretiens de robert guédiguian qui
est sorti aux liens qui libèrent et le
nouvel album de vanessa benelli moselle
il est consacré à claude debussy vous
serez à la philharmonie de paris le 28
novembre avec l'orchestré avec les
musiciens de la caisse de paris pour
jouer nino rota intime merci de nous
avoir suivis à puis je rappelle twist à
bamako le 5 janvier au cinéma le
prochain film de de robert guédiguian
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]